après le succès du premier tome l'équipe
de tubes onia a décidé de lancer une
nouvelle campagne de financement
participatif pour passer au tome 2 de
cette bd des aventures médiévales des
youtuber francophone pour le tome 1 ils
ont réussi à collecter plus de 500000
euros alors que leur objectif n'était
que de 15 mille euros c'est ce qu'on
appelle un succès de malades pour le
tome 2 l'objectif est le même mais alors
que la campagne a été lancée le 8
octobre et qu'elle finit le 7 décembre
l'objectif de 15000 euros à d'ores et
déjà été exposée mais jusqu'où ira-t-il
quel sera le financement total que
recevra cette campagne un quoi je fais
du placement de produit ok j'avoue j'ai
un petit intérêt dans cette histoire
puisque une rumeur dit que je serais
probablement dans l'histoire du tome 2
et jouera peut-être même l'occasion de
faire un spin off dont le monde
rocambolesque du tube scientifique vent
ça c'est s'il ya un public pour ça
à tout hasard y aurait-il un public pour
ça mais revenons-en à la campagne
d'après vous combien d'argent sera
récoltée par t-bone ya 2 le 7 décembre à
23h59
quelle sera la somme totale du
financement participatif de tubes on ya
2 alors bien sûr vous pourriez donner un
nombre comme 6 millions 280 3185 euros
mais ce nombre ce ne sera très
probablement parts égales au financement
exact de tubes baignade comme on l'a vu
la dernière fois utilisé des nombre
précis ne semblent généralement pas
adéquats notamment car ceux ci haut mais
la description de notre incertitudes
l'idéal serait en fait de décrire une
distribution probabiliste mais ce
langage des probabilités est très
complexe à communiquer et à manipuler
en fait la dernière fois je vous ai
encouragés à raisonner avec les
intervalles car il semble s'agir d'un
langage adéquat entre la rigueur
déraisonnable du parisianisme et la
simplicité dangereuse les estimations
moyennes
on a aussi vu quand statistique on
savait pull est souvent sur des notions
distinctes d'intervalle à savoir les
intervalles de fluctuation qui prédisent
les fluctuations d'une collecte de
données à l'autre et les intervalles de
confiance dont on n'a vu qu'une
interprétation adéquate était en fait un
peu délicate
en fait le domaine d'applicabilité des
intervalles de fluctuation et de
confiance semblent très limitées
en tout cas dans leurs formes classiques
en particulier elle ne semble pas
inclure le cas du financement
participatif de tubes on a deux or
prédire le financement participatif de
tubes on ya 2 est le genre de questions
vraiment utile en pratique
c'est ce genre de prédiction qui va
motiver des entrepreneurs à entreprendre
des investisseurs à investir des
collaborateurs un collaborer et des
clients à clientes et clients talisay
clients elysées peut-on malgré tout
utilisé des intervalles pour parler du
financement participatif total qui sera
probablement reçu par t-bone ya deux
ports heureusement oui il est même tout
à fait possible de rendre ce langage des
intervalles rigoureux l'astuce est temps
de s'appuyer sur le langage des
intervalles de créances l'idée des
intervalles de crédence c'est de
s'appuyer sur les lois des probabilités
et d'ensuite cherchait une façon
d'approcher ces lois des probabilités
souvenez vous par exemple que les
quantités d'intérêt au bayer siens sont
de la forme probabilité de la théorie
sachant les données pour déterminer les
crédences de diverses théories ou de la
forme probabilité de x sachant d quand
il s'agit de prédire une donnée encore
inconnue x
sachant les données des collecter jusque
là alors de façon générale tsx ne
correspondent pas nécessairement à des
nombres
ce qui fait que l'on ne peut pas
toujours parler naturellement
l'intervalle de crédence portée et x
cependant on peut souvent si ramené par
exemple en s'intéressant à des données x
après dire qu'ils sont effectivement des
nombres comme c'est le cas du montant
total qui aura été collectées par t-bone
ya 2 dès lors on pourra naturellement
définir un intervalle de crédence pour x
dans le cas des théories il est aussi
possible de définir des intervalles de
crédence pour des théories qui sont
paramétrés par des paramètres numérique
considérons par exemple une météorite
est paramétré par un nombre d'états on
peut alors calculer la crédence de
l'état sachant les données collectées
mais pour y arriver il nous faut d'abord
supposer que la théorie t est vrai pour
une valeur de l'état autrement dit ce
qu'on va être a ensuite amené à calculer
et quelque chose comme la probabilité de
teta sachant les données d et la théorie
et et là on a bien une probabilité sur
un nombre
on peut donc aussi bien parlé de
probabilités sur un nombre qui est une
donnée x qui sera observée ou sur un
nombre qui est un paramètre d'une
théorie lorsque l'on suppose la théorie
vrai le problème bien sûr c'est que ces
probabilités peuvent être dur à décrire
et complexes à manipuler l'astuce pour y
arriver est de remplacer les
probabilités probabilité de x a changé
et probabilité de l'état sachant d été
par des intervalles intervalle sur x
sachant d et intervalles sûreté pas
sachant d été
ces intervalles seront des outils pour
donner une représentation simplifiée
mais assez représentative des
probabilités probabilité de x à chandai
les probabilités de teta sachant d été
alors pour être bien défini à l'instar
des intervalles de fluctuation et de
confiance
il est utile d'introduire un niveau de
crédence un intervalle sur x à 95 %
sachant dès que j'ai noté pour
aujourd'hui
ic 95% de x sachant d sera alors un
intervalle tels que la probabilité que x
soit effectivement dans cet intervalle
sachant d est égal à 95%
autrement dit la propriété fondamentale
dans l'intervalle de crédence à 95% et
d'être valide avec crédence 95%
ceci se traduit mathématiquement par
l'égalité probabilité sur x que x
appartient à l'intervalle 95% de x
sachant dès le tout sachant d est égal à
95%
tout simplement ou presque bien souvent
étant donné une probabilité a posteriori
sur x il existe en fait plusieurs
intervalles de crédence à 95% qui
correspondent à cette distribution
probabiliste mais comme on peut le voir
intuitivement
tous ne se valent pas on tue tivement un
intervalle de crédence est meilleur s'il
est plus petit et bien on peut définir
de manière presque unique l'intervalle
ic 95 % ic sachant d comme étant le plus
petit intervalle dont la crédence et 95
% dans le cas notamment des courbes de
distribution probabilités dit unis modal
on peut démontrer que cet intervalle
s'obtient en faisant glisser un seuil
verticale de haut en bas
jusqu'à ce que l'ensemble des valeurs de
x pour lesquels la fonction de densité
est au dessus du seuil correspondent un
intervalle à 95% et ce qui est cool
c'est que tout ceci semble parfaitement
s'appliquer au cas de thibault n'ya de
votre prédiction probabiliste sur la
somme totale collectée ressemble
peut-être à ça un truc à mi chemin entre
une loi normale et une loi log normal il
ya des bonnes raisons de penser ça mais
je laisse ces détails techniques pour
une prochaine fois
eh bien à partir de cette courbe vous
pouvez construire un intervalle de
crédence qu'ici correspond à cet
intervalle ici n'est a priori cet
intervalle devrait être valide à 95% ou
plutôt la propriété crucial des
intervalles de crédence à 95% en
particulier sur des données futur c'est
qu'il devrait être valide plus ou moins
95% du temps avec quelques bémols
technique et ce qui est très intéressant
avec ça c'est comme vous exerçant a
prédit régulièrement des intervalles de
crédence à 4 1 15%
vous serez bien plus à même de juger
quel est le niveau d'incertitude adéquat
qui vous faut avoir dans telle ou telle
situation c'est pour ça que je
recommande très vivement l'utilisation
des intervalles de crédence dans votre
quotidien
ce sont des outils indispensables pour
mesurer notre excès de confiance et
l'étendue de notre ignorance typiquement
civaux intervalle de crédence à 95% sont
faux 20% du temps c'est que vous êtes en
excès de confiance
vos prédictions donc d'incertitude et
bien sûr je parlais site d intervalle à
95%
mais je vous invite également à parler
des intervalles de crédence à 50% à 80%
à 86 9% voire à 99 99% en particulier
dans ce dernier cas votre intervalle
devrait vraiment presque toujours
contenir la valeur que vous prédisez ce
qui devrait vous forcer à étaler vos
intervalles
par ailleurs si vous arrivez à mieux
ajuster votre degré de confiance adéquat
que julia f appelle la calibration de
votre degré de confiance
l'étalement de vaud intervalle de
crédence mesurera alors parfaitement
l'étendue de votre ignorance et ça c'est
super important non seulement parce que
ça vous aidera à mieux mesurer votre
ignorance et la modestie épistémique
adéquate à avoir mais aussi parce que ça
permet de mieux cerner ce que vous
ignorez est donc ce qu'il vous est le
plus souhaitable qu'à prendre après tout
une serre sans doute pas à grand chose
de continuer à investiguer un sujet pour
lequel votre ignorance est en fait
faible votre investigation ne réduira
pas grandement votre ignorance
al'inverse s'il est un sujet important à
propos duquel tous vos intervalle de
crédence sont énormes
il se pourrait qu'il soit une bonne idée
de vous informer à ce sujet pour réduire
la taille de ces intervalles de crédence
tout en gardant le même degré de
crédence pour toutes ces raisons je vous
invite à souvent parié des intervalles
de crédence que ce soit sur le temps
d'attenté en bus sur le prix d'un objet
que vous voulez acheter sur le nombre de
personnes présentes dans une soirée sur
le nombre d'habitants à lausanne ou sur
le nombre de réponses quand je cherche
et à ses petits sur google scholar
personnellement ça fait un an ou deux
que j'ai pris l'habitude de mesurer
régulièrement mais intervalle de
crédence et de l'est confrontés
régulièrement ou données empiriques pour
tester mon excès de confiance et il me
semble que ce faisant j'ai énormément
appris sur l'étendue de mon ignorance ce
qui m'a permis de mieux prioriser les
questions et les
approfondir je ne peut que vivement vous
conseillé d'en faire de même et surtout
d'y voir un jeu ludique et amusant qui
vous oppose vous avoue biais cognitif
en particulier je vous invite à mettre
en commentaire vaut intervalle de
crédence à 95 % pour le montant total
qui aura été collectés par la campagne
de financement participatif du boni à
deux ainsi que si vous êtes motivés les
intervalles à d'autres niveaux de
crédence nanar pas vous m'avez demandé
de donner plus d'illustrations les
intervalles de fluctuation et des
intervalles de confiance sachant
notamment que maintenant ces concepts
sont au programme des mathématiques de
lycées s'il ne trompent pas donc à ce
sujet je recommande notamment la vidéo
d'yvan gars qui parle et qui donne un
exemple de cela
typiquement le cas d'application de ces
intervalles c'est vraiment un cadre
ultra afrique en piste qui correspond à
l'échantillonnage c'est à dire on a une
population donnée
et on veut savoir dans la population
française disons qu'elle est par exemple
le pourcentage de personnes qui
connaissent la formule de bise ou plutôt
disons qu'ils répondent oui à la
question est ce que vous connaissez le
théorème de baïse
pour répondre à ce genre de questions
dans les sondages en pratique ce qu'ils
soient en fait c'est qu'on va
sélectionner dix ont mille personnes de
la population française à qui on va
effectivement posé la question et du
coup on va avoir une données empiriques
qui correspond à ce cet échantillon qui
a été sélectionné de la population on
aura en particulier une donnée f qui
correspondra à la fréquence à laquelle
les 1000 participants des soupes du
sondage ont répondu oui à la question
est ce que vous connaissez le théorème
de baisse
ce qui est important à voir c'est que
ici f elle a donné alors qu'en fait ce
qui intéresse souvent les gens qui
effectuent ce genre de sondage c'est de
savoir plutôt qu'à la proportion paix de
gens qui aura répondu oui si on
considérait toute la population
française donc ici dans ses cales en
fait on a un modèle dans lequel on
suppose qu'il existe cette proportion
paix de réponse oui à la question est ce
que vous connaissez le terrain de
l'obèse s'ils en sont de toute la
population française est important de
voir que cette proportion paix est une
proportion purement théorique elle
correspond à aucune donnée que loin
c'est le résultat d'un modèle que l'on a
qui présuppose que on peut poser cette
question à toute la population française
et que en demandant à tout le monde on
aurait la réponse à cette question qui
est intéressant avec cette théorie de
l'existence de cette proportion p c'est
que du coup elle permet de faire des
prédictions notamment sur les valeurs de
f auquel on peut s'attendre donc
imaginons que l'on considère une théorie
tu es dans laquelle la proportion de
français qui connaissent l'auteur de
baise est égale à 5%
eh bien il faut s'attendre à ce que sur
les 1000 personnes qui ont été sondés
au hasard qui ont été tirés au hasard il
n'y aura pas exactement 5 % de réponses
où il n'y aura pas exactement cinquante
personnes qui répondront oui mais il y
aura quelque chose autour de quarante à
soixante dix on est surtout si on fait
le sondage une fois et puis si on refait
le sondage avec mille autres personnes
et bien cette fréquence f qu'on calcule
ne sera pas toujours la même sera sont
autour de 5% c'est ce que prédit micro
théorie mais ne sera jamais exactement
la même
un intervalle de fluctuation à 95% il
serait valide pour environ 95 des 100
sondage que l'on aura fait ainsi
j'espère qu'avec cet exemple vous voyez
bien que l'intervalle de fluctuation
correspond à une prédiction sur une
donnée qui sera observée ou qui a déjà
été observée mais c'est une donnée
observable alors que la proportion paix
qu'on a imaginé dans notre théorie c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas observateurs
correspond à aucune données empiriques
et tout le problème de l'intervalle de
confiance et essayer de trouver où
pourrait être cette valeur op sachant
uniquement une valeur f qui a été
mesurée dans un sondage donc imaginer
non pardon pour un effet un sondage et
qui on a eu 47
réponse oui la question qu'est ce qu'on
peut imaginer sur la valeur de paix deux
cas c'est la question à laquelle essaie
de répondre l'intervalle de confiance
alors dans cet exemple qui est vraiment
l'archétype dans lequel on a introduit
les intervalles de confiance on obtient
assez raisonnablement que cette
proportion pl paraît pas non plus
complètement métaphysique paraît pas non
plus complètement déraisonnable et le
fait qu'on s'appuie souvent sur ce genre
d'exemple peut donner l'impression que
les intervalles de confiance sont ne
sont pas métaphysique mais souvent en
fait on va calculer des intervalles de
confiance sur des paramètres de modèles
par exemple de cosmologie
alors que le modèle lui-même de
cosmologie et cette théorie cosmologique
finalement elle n'est peut-être pas si
fiable que cela en elle-même
et c'est en cela que police parle de
paramètres métaphysique et dans ce genre
de cas l'interprétation en tout cas des
intervalles de confiance paraît beaucoup
plus douteuses et potentiellement
problématique
et puis par ailleurs il y a le problème
qui vient du fait que si on fait des
sondages sur toute une population
il ya une probabilité non nul qu'on
trouve parfois des sondages vraiment
vraiment surprenant donc imaginons qu'on
ait tiré un sondage est en fait qu'ils
aient eu des artefacts dans la manière
dont tu as fait le sondage qui font que
en fait on a trouvé que 100 % des gens
connaissent effectivement la forme de
baisses typiquement parce qu'on est
tombé sur un échantillon qui
correspondaient à des joueurs de saint
roch ça peut arriver à ce moment là il
sera en fête les très fallacieux de
penser que l'intervalle de confiance on
pourra avoir calculé ainsi avec leur
fraction f qu'on aura observé
correspondre à un intervalle dans lequel
la proportion paix et se trouvent très
probablement
c'est à cause de ce genre d'artefacts
qu'il faut avoir anticipé notamment à
l'aide de préjugés que les intervalles
de confiance pouvait être extrêmement
trompeurs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il vaut mieux se méfier au
moins un petit peu des intervalles de
confiance surtout dès lors qu' il ya des
risques de facteurs de confusion où dès
lors qu'il y a des préjugés très marqués
à avoir l espère que vous avez mais
chaque vidéo là présentement on va
essayer d'appliquer un peu tout ça je
vais raisonnement croyez que façon assez
générale au problème du principe de
précaution
question en particulier des précautions
à avoir quand on utilise le principe de
précaution si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la laquelle a commenté à
l'apartheid pense que les abonnés pour
l'épisode merci au super power dont et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
foire prédire le futur c'est compliqué
et annoncer de grandes dates de façon
péremptoire
ça ne rend pas bien compte de notre
degré d'incertitude alors est-ce qu'il
faut renoncer à faire des prédictions
non bien sûr mais il faudrait plutôt
faire des prédictions probabiliste par
exemple on peut se demander avec les
infos qu'on a aujourd'hui quelle est la
probabilité que x se produisent avant
2050 ce qui me semble être un débat
beaucoup plus intéressant